biotonix et squeeze oui ceci représente
la fatigue mais je ne sais pas c'est
fatigués au point de ne pas vous inviter
dans le sens de coiffure quand même
quand même aujourd'hui on se retrouve
sur un des premiers jeux j'ai téléchargé
quand j'ai eu mon ipad au krc lumbi j'ai
connu parce qu'il est sûr pas malde ipad
en expo dans les magasins d'électronique
bref semblait steak
en fait je trouve assez marrant parce
qu'il faut prendre une photo de soi
ailleurs sutton se coiffe nous-mêmes
voilà est d'ailleurs j'avais bien besoin
on peut le dire parfait ça fera bien le
travail demandé il penche d'un côté
carrément c'est leur droit le plus
marrant il est trop bien fait c'est pour
ça que j'adore ce jeu ria et la crue
station est tellement bien fait
bon déjà la coupe par les fouilles plus
strictes les mèches pas trop comment le
prendre
donc je n'ai pas le prendre et là on
peut coiffer vous voyez un nom j'ai
coupé d'office quoi d'entrée de jeu on
peut payer tout ça par exemple pour ce
faire une coupe toujours quoi qu'on
fasse un but steve et moi deux manières
up la voilà la petite crête vient bien
belle les mains qui arrive à parler aux
gens un cul-de-poule regarder les comme
ça mais il peut parler on peut les c'est
quoi ça les freeze ou oui les frisés ya
finalement on obtient une botte de foin
on peut les lycées on peut les c'est
quoi ça les brûler tu pourras chalumeau
comme ça sur le sur la planche
bon je me coiffe mois puisque mon salon
et ensuite on coiffera des personnalités
très connues oui puisque bon je suis un
petit nombre de la coiffure moi je ne
vois deux filles je carrément un mec
or on aurait dit un pont un pont qui
drague un autre pan c'était incroyable
comme scène voilà la coupe du paon on va
couper un peu quand même mais pas trop
voilà le petit pan le bébé pans entiers
plus accessoire tout de même
oh oui hier il a fait un clin d'oeil ça
veut dire qu'il a bien aimé bas juste
rajouter un petit nom comme ça et
petites fleurs dans les cheveux quand
même pour faire le paon un peu style et
là c'est la perfection hors de la photo
elle est belle
oh oui oh comme c'est beau j'appelle
dans mon salon boîte l'épongé alors on
va lui faire une belle coupe un peu plus
pour juin ait tellement bien fait allez
bob l'eponge laisse-toi ferme autant
fait pas patrick va encore plus tu
aimais après attendait six jeux d'été en
jaune
ça va être carrément bond fait j'ai bob
l'eponge qui s'est mis quelques bigoudis
1a et la rigolade a blagué vue c'est
bien seul tout d'un côté sinon nous tous
sur la tête sinon voilà comme ça la
coupe abat jour c'est pas mal
ben je pense qu'il faut lui faire des
petites bouclettes envoyer du bois aussi
que c'est le plein là c'est parfait
y'a plus qu'à les dresser une mèche
comme ça vers le haut la perfection et
voilà voilà quelque chose de plus
affiché sur le mur de mon salon de
coiffure et maintenant j'appelle
quelqu'un qui a vraiment des cheveux luc
utile à des cheveux alors là oh merde
voilà là mais regardez-moi ça c'est
magnifique
faut-il est pas du tout et j'ai la même
personne âgée qui s'est jetée dans une
flaque d'eau verte quoi ça craint on
dirait pas un petit peu quelqu'un de
2750 la sorte de ministre un peu
ministre de la coiffure je dirais même
ministre du style et là il est vraiment
beau gosse si hulk avait eu les cheveux
longs et ce qu'il aurait encore été
crédible déjà il aurait tapé ses
coéquipiers parce qu'ils voient plus
rien voilà une coupe vraiment qui a du
sens bravo pour ta nouvelle coupe c'est
bien voilà quand même quand même s'il
vous plaît j'appelle au siège tort le
coéquipier de hulk bon bah voilà enfin
[ __ ] doit même pas tort quoi on dirait
tout sauf tort on a juste un mec au pif
qui a un gros nez quoi bon pour le coup
il ya une vraie coupe noram ans plus
tard donc bombay essayer de faire
quelque chose de bien
1 donc on va te mettre tout ça en blanc
y compris sur le visage la barbe
je veux ta barbe alors là c'est d'une
beauté mais extrêmes on n'a tout
simplement jamais vu ça dans l'histoire
d'un super-héros et heureusement
d'ailleurs
elle m'a franchement tort si tu avais eu
cette coupe déjà tu serais pas un dieu
et en plus tu n'en ai jamais fait partie
de l'équipe d'avengers j'appelle
désormais au siège gollum elle vous prêt
à voir gollum un battant mais tu sais
pas si avec sa bouche
ils essaient d'imiter il est séduite et
moi au début de la vidéo tu veux la même
courbe est comme ça malika parfois mais
je vais de coiffer au calme toi
calme-toi déjà ya aucun problème avec ça
on va tous les organes glover d'un
groupe de rock
hier annonçant un an et j'ai envie j'ai
envie d'en rester là vraiment j'ai envie
de rester là peut-être une idée les
cheveux plus longs pour qu'ils aient la
mèche encore plus longue que la mèche
soit relié à sa petite barbe du menton
suisse lapointe lapointe lapointe
magnifique magnifique
c'est incroyable ce qui vient de se
passer photo instantanée tu n'as pas le
choix gaulle où je voulais une autre
coupe c'est pas grave tu refuse de payer
c'est pas grave parce que nous si ta
tête qu'on se paye et franchement ça
faisait longtemps que je fasse tout un
jeu beau comme ça bah non
j'aimerais bien qui clignent des yeux
rouges prennent la photo mais on dirait
ici à comme un grand-père en fait gollum
mois ci voilà je voulais grand perte a
retouché pas ce qui se passe aux deux
ans mercy goloumo jeu c'est iron man et
si iron man avec des cheveux aux alors
qu'est-ce qu'il aurait eu comme coupaye
romani funk ou plutôt bien par contre il
faut une coupe qui fasse peur à je pense
michael mann avait des cheveux savourer
ressembler à ça il aurait perdu toute
crédibilité il serait pas non plus dans
la veine je n'en suis pas convaincu de
mon travail des artistes coiffeurs voilà
voilà la coupe qu iron man aurait vu
l'essor de poteaux de rugby sur la tête
avec une petite frange quand même
qui sera le suivant un personnage qui
ressemble fortement à gollum qui lui
ressemble parce qu'il est chaud veulent
deux morts et six vols de mort a vu les
cheveux et ses vols de mort se gratter
les yeux avec ses cheveux comme ceux ci
la danse des cheveux là il fait danser
ses cheveux tellement beau mail harry
potter posture battus pour depuis la
série était une vraie histoire d'amour
finalement un film d'amour en fait il y
aurait plus de méchants la d'oreilles
potter hermione à la route sont bonnes
avec hagrid à je sais j'ai toujours rêvé
de voir voldemort comme ça d un jeu vous
devez le voir comme ça ma tête quand
j'étais petit ce qui me faisait peur
voldemort avec la coupe de torts mais en
boucle et voilà au regard des fleurs il
a pas ça mais ne pleure flammes et ne
t'en fais pas moi la bafin boom là il a
fait son plus beau sourire un sourire la
baule de mort mesdames et messieurs à
tonnerre d'applaudissements pardon pour
cheikh aweys génial
alors ta petite fille yonah on va la
séduire comme il se doit que ton crâne
chauve elles sont hélas est presque
thème bien ta coupe des mois tous oui
bah qui rigole consent une partie fusée
à droite une partie vit sa gauche en
repiquant le tout légèrement pour que ça
ça semble
et voilà et au milieu il ya un coeur un
lieu heureusement silva 3 formats qu on
attendait ces médias dur je n'arrive pas
à faire le coeur shrek [ __ ] et chaque
tu vas finir le crâne chauve vrai tu vas
pas faire chier je veux plus te voir
on va juste laisser ta bouche comme ça
il pourra quand même temps bras c'est ce
qu'on appelle une tête de bush ça me
plaît beaucoup elle est belle je suis
tenté un truc sait pas trop ce que ça va
donner
est il possible de coiffer un poisson de
coiffer le beau oui c'est lui
oui mais quel que voulez vous faire un
poisson une coupe en aileron police et
une mèche et l'âme est toute droite se
révéleront parfait l'aileron dont il a
toujours rêvé
oh là là parfait il va nager encore plus
vite avec ça n'est pas une petite
histoire pour les mots année mais c'est
parfait fournée bororo dieu qu'il est
parfaitement oui on a rarement vu un
héros aussi stylée elle est belle elle
le clin d'oeil on le connaît on aime on
la prie si vous le dire aux clients
suivants s'il vous plaît batman on t'a
vu on t'a reconnu tu en as marre du
masque c'est ça tu veux adopter les
cheveux tu veux te cacher derrière tu
veux que je fasse un masque bonbons ça
peut-être un peu de gratter le front et
voilà le masque de cheveux c'est parfait
la petite moustache et story batman
oh oui je sais je sais quelqu'un dont
j'ai toujours rêvé de changer la coupe
de cheveux mon beau temps n'est pas
forcément mauvaise et
et naruto et voilà c'est bon allez j'ai
rien à toucher les parfaites comme ça à
temps il faut des petites mèches de
ninja quand même petite tache qui
prennent bien le vent quand tu cours sur
les arbres ah je sais comment regarder
leurs images souvent vas-y naruto cours
voilà là où tous à l'école et là c'est
le moment toutes les filles vont adorer
ah ah non elle est dégueulasse sachent
quoi il sait le faire une sorte du match
à mignon mais il est carrément
dégueulasse bontempi ok on va faire une
coupe assorti à sa moustache
voilà la coupe a sorti à la moustache
c'est très beau en fait nous sommes
carrément la coupe qu'on a fait tout à
l'heure elle est belle elle est belle si
optimus prime avait eu une coupe de
cheveux escarmant violer c'est pas grave
c'est très bien ça c'est quand beac le
bleu et site avec toi t'aurais une
frange ce secteur une frange au four
était comme ça ma belle optimus voilà
optimus prime a compris par les autres
il a l'air tellement malheureux voilà
comme ça au fait les bugs derniers
clients charlie chaplin
par contre pour lui je sais déjà qu'elle
coupe faire vous allez voir le talent en
action elle est belle elle est belle
[ __ ] c'est le succès de la journée
bon ben voilà gens c'est la fin de cette
vidéo sur toquer à salaunes législation
aura plus et camille c'était pas mal m
dos apparemment plaisir et dites moi
quel personnage vous avez préféré dans
les commentaires mon petit préféré à moi
ces gaulois bien aux settons stream une
hausse de belles vidéos tient tout le
monde
pis
[Musique]